you are safe behind your shields and the
orcs are going to impale themselves on
your pointy sticks and then the elves
just decide no instead we'll jump in
front of that and put ourselves
needlessly into danger my name is luke
nyendag i teach ancient history at the
university of edinburgh you might
remember me from part one today we'll be
looking at ancient warfare scenes in
modern movies and tv and seeing how real
they are
no
draw
all these movies do this they will have
these archers lined up they give this
sequence of knock draw loose over and
over again
but this never happened you don't order
them to shoot in volleys when you order
everyone to draw at the same time some
of these guys are going to get really
tired and they're not going to be
effective others are going to be like
this is too slow for me i can shoot
faster than this there were no orders to
archers to fire and volleys
the coordination required to do this is
completely impossible there were battle
formations where you would have shield
balls in front and then spears sticking
out to sort of drive the enemy back
obviously the macedonian pikemen are the
big famous example there are
mesopotamian examples from like way back
2000 bc it wouldn't work like this
though you couldn't really form them in
a circle they would form up in blocks
and they would maneuver in blocks and
that's hard enough
once you're fully surrounded i mean
there's nothing you can do really
you're in big trouble you can try to
break the spears persians are known to
do that against the greeks their spears
are longer so they literally went up and
snapped them in half by hand but that's
a desperation move and it doesn't really
get you anywhere if you're in an
encirclement like that of a proper pike
formation then you're just doomed you
probably surrender
[Music]
crushes in battle do happen
but most of the time when people do get
crushed into a small space and the dead
start piling up it's because they're
trying to run away and they can't escape
because there's a river or ravine or a
wall and they get stuck there the panic
of a trampole they do depict that very
well
when horses turn up unexpectedly
especially behind the infantry line you
would give up and run there is almost no
chance that that formation would hold
the very unrealistic thing in this scene
is that no one knew that cavalry was
there it's possible to hide you know
small units in in woods or hollow roads
or behind some geographical feature
but a large force of cavalry is going to
throw up a lot of dust it's going to
make a lot of noise it's going to you
know scare the birds and the animals you
know this is coming i think this one
does a an interesting job of trying to
give you the sort of visceral horror of
a battle and i really do appreciate that
the tactics are nonsense but it does
give a sense of desperation of some of
these struggles so maybe five out of ten
six out of ten
[Music]
that big horn is supposed to be like a
morale boost and in that sense it can
work a lot of troops before battle would
try to sing songs together just like
sports teams might do
um to hype them up so that kind of thing
would work for horn that shouldn't be
confused with the idea of using it to
give orders that's a separate thing the
romans were very good at that they had a
number of like different trumpet signals
and the troops all knew like if you hear
this signal if you hear that signal you
have to do different things but for
instance the greeks i mean they had one
big trumpet when it sounded you charge
if it sounds again you retreat
that's it
why would you do that
[Music]
like why would they try to get the
cavalry to slide over the shield wall
into their own formation you want the
cavalry to stop in front of you because
at the moment that cavalry stops and is
stuck in front of your spear wall they
lose all their advantages they're not
mobile anymore they don't have that
momentum anymore the
elves clearly have a very effective
spear wall and then they just duck under
it and let the cavalry slide over
what
i don't know why i don't know what they
were doing
[Applause]
both the elves and the dwarves in this
one have this double layered shield wall
there are battle formations where you
would do that where you would try to
stop cavalry by building these double
layered shield walls this is based on
like a late roman infantry formation
where you put your infantry close
together at the front in double shield
walls or even triple shield wall but in
most battles it's such a static
formation
it removes all your opportunities to
maneuver or to move
you wouldn't want to do that unless you
were absolutely sure what the enemy was
going to do was going to be running
straight into you if there was anything
else they might do you want to keep your
flexibility by keeping your line
separated and just rely on a single wall
of shields because that will do most of
the time
if you've got a static defense you have
your spear wall the orcs are charging
straight into it with no sense of self
preservation that's exactly what you
want them to do right you are safe
behind your shields and the orcs are
going to impale themselves on your
pointy sticks all you want to have is
for that to be exactly like that until
the orcs stopped coming and then the
elves just decide no instead we'll jump
in front of that and put ourselves
needlessly into danger so we can fight
these forks hand to hand it makes no
sense it serves no purpose
[Applause]
wedge formations
are debated because on the one hand we
have a lot of sources saying that wedge
formations existed mainly for cavalry
but it's not entirely certain how that
would even work because most of what
you're doing is just putting one guy at
the front who's going to be exposed to
everyone in the enemy line so unless
you've already made a hole that wedge is
not going to give you any advantage it's
just actually going to put you in a
really dangerous position where you're
feeding your men one at a time into the
enemy with cavalry it's not clear
whether it even works it's showing you
some interesting heavy infantry
formations but otherwise like four out
of ten
[Music]
so this is kubrick trying to visualize a
real roman
battle formation which is this
three lines in a checkerboard
which going into battle they would
actually try and form some kind of line
we're not actually sure how this worked
it's also possible that they actually
fought in these checkerboards which
would give them room to sort of withdraw
between the ranks of the others and sort
of maneuver in and out when the front
was getting tired or when it was
suffering too many casualties and when
it couldn't get through you just pull
them back and send in the second line
which would consist of more experienced
troops and then they would have a go
this is just an enormous mob of guys
much too deep to serve any purpose
like get information
[Music]
oh no it landed on him
[Applause]
i could bounced over the one and landed
on the other guy oh i hope he got his
paycheck
killed by a massive flaming corn dog
excellent work hollywood just likes fire
they just want to have fire in their
battles they want to throw big balls of
fire and they want to have rollers of
fire and balls of fire to disrupt
formations it seems to work in theory
because you want these orderly
formations disrupted in that sense it
makes tactical sense
[Music]
the casualty rate of these battles in
hollywood is ridiculous the result is
always that everyone dies this is just
not how battles work you have a certain
number of men in a formation and when
they start to see the things going
against them or especially when they
realize they've lost order they're going
to retreat they're going to get out of
there and then they'll see what happens
next or if the enemy is running away and
they're being chased by cavalry that's
when you see the real casualties pile up
but in these formation battles most of
the time casualties would be quite low 6
out of 10 for trying
it must have been an enormous effort to
try and get all these extras trained to
do this
and then they get rolled over by flaming
corn dogs it's a missed opportunity that
poor guy i hope he's well i hope he's
still around
battles on ice did happen
there's very famously there's the battle
on the ice
which is a battle in which
the republic of novgorod warded off the
teutonic knights and so there was a
battle fought on the ice
because obviously in many parts if
you're fighting in winter the ice offers
a nice flat space where you can maneuver
easily
[Music]
i mean archers would have different
ranges based on what kind of bow they
were using what kind of arrow they were
using and of course their individual
experience and skill any kind of
effective missile is not going to be too
too much effective by the way and it
doesn't necessarily matter that much
where they end up as long as they still
have some force when they land aim for
the wings of the ranks make them cluster
i really like it actually that they use
the arrows to drive them together
so they use these arrows around the
edges to sort of drive the enemy into a
narrow space where his numbers are
negated that would generally have been
used in battle so we say six out of ten
okay so you've got a huge line at the
back and then there's another line much
closer so there's like a mile between
those two what is the line of the back
even doing it's going to take you 15
minutes just to walk into the battle
this is the worst example of a hollywood
fight
you have big armies but they don't
don't act like armies at all slashing
left and right no one knows what's going
on there's no formations it seems like
there has been no preparation no
planning whatsoever everybody just gets
together in a big mob and then slams
into each other
is such a weird scene because you see
heads being split left and right and
then suddenly when the flop needs it to
happen there's a nice little pause and
nobody will bother her for a little bit
while she mourns this guy
it's very nice of them to let her do
that
if you turn away from the fighting and
drop your weapon in this kind of melee
that someone is going to shank you this
is obviously something they do for plot
reasons which is totally understandable
it's one out of ten it's a complete
disaster of a depiction of battle
i don't want to keep delivering this
point but you should be digging ditches
many ditches once your first stitch is
ready build another one dig many ditches
just lots and lots of ditches again
where is your ditch where is your ditch
you've got to have a ditch
it shows the strength of this kind of
fortification because the horses aren't
going to try and go into those ditches
they're going to try to avoid that
difficult terrain and that allows you to
force the enemy into where you want to
fight them so that is actually a very
very good demonstration of how ditches
are supposed to work and how a very
simple thing like digging a pit can
actually help you enormously
this is an absolute massacre this
depiction of the battle it's it's
reasonably accurate according to the
accounts that survive so
we know that this was fought in a
deliberately narrow space they chose a
place that was surrounded by marshes so
that the enemy cavalry which was very
strong would have to funnel itself along
one small narrow causeway if you're
cavalry you want flat ground because
then you can move quickly and move
freely
[Applause]
in the movies everybody slams together
and then it's just a huge melee
obviously in real life there's only a
few men who are able to fight
and the rest are just kind of waiting
for their turn more or less and
especially if you're in a battle like
loudoun hill where you're funneled into
a narrow terrain so they chose their
terrain really well and that meant that
even though the english had numerical
advantage they couldn't use it
for this kind of battle is realistic and
it sounds like they're just shouting and
hoping that the men around them will
hear it and then those men will sort of
pass it on
this is obviously not a perfect system
so he would just hope that everybody
would follow his example most of the
time so it explains the the tactics the
principles but there are some other
problems all the infantry has too much
armor and all the horses have not enough
armor
seven out ten
[Applause]
so this is alexander's battle against
the indians at the harassments which is
in modern day pakistan it wasn't fought
in a wood it was fought on the on the
banks of a river which alexander had
crossed in the night so for alexander in
particular as cavalry as it is trump
card he wants to be able to use his
cavalry and that means he wants to fight
in open spaces he wants to be able to
maneuver them easily and he wants them
to be able to run freely in a wood it's
too much for them to trip over you can't
maintain your cavalry formation very
closely effective heavy cavalry also
works in quite tight formations like
these horses are shoulder to shoulder if
you want to use that effectively you
can't obviously go through trees so he
would try to avoid them all of his major
battles tend to be fought on the banks
of rivers or in open plains
this was the big battle where alexander
first encountered elephants and they're
depicting this you know part of this
really well horses don't like animals
they don't know you run your elephants
at them and if they haven't seen them
before if they haven't gotten used to
each other
then the the horses are going to run
away first you can see this these
elephants sort of barging into these
heavy infantry formations and
everybody's like what are these how do
we stop these but actually alexander won
this battle quite handily
the fact is that once you're over the
initial shock and you have troops that
are battle-hardened it's quite easy to
drive off elephants simply by throwing
missiles at them trying to get rid of
their riders and panicking them so that
they'll turn around and run and trample
their own men which is very often what
would happen with these elephants but at
least you know you know the equipments
the tactics of the of the individual
warriors and all that is is accurate
you're 7 out of 10.
so hollow square is a real formation it
will be used on the march if you were
afraid that uh the enemy might ambush
you or might attack you they would be
able to turn at moment's notice
depending on where the threat was going
to come from
so chariots are a feature of mostly
bronze age warfare they are meant to
carry around people who are shooting
arrows or throwing javelins usually in
very large numbers but as soon as you
have mounted cavalry and you've mastered
the art of firing missiles from
horseback the chariot is essentially
obsolete it has no real advantages over
just having lots of men on horseback
because they're more flexible so
chariots in in the course of antiquity
just kind of go out of style that would
give it like five out of ten
[Applause]
it's actually nice to see a bit of
diversity in this scene like the roman
empire obviously stretched across the
mediterranean into africa all over
europe so you'd actually have people you
know
different skin colors different
backgrounds
so they dug a ditch and then they hit it
it does happen
it can be done there is at least one
battle in greek history where the enemy
has a lot of cavalry storming at uh at
the defenders and the defenders have
prepared the ground by burying these
pots in the ground just big basses and
then hiding them so that when the
cavalry charges they fall into the pots
and they break their legs so this kind
of hidden trap
isn't completely unheard of but it
couldn't be done on this scale because
you'd see it right i mean the effort it
would take to hide a ditch on that
massive scale is just incomprehensible
and they would know that these works
were going on because you didn't just
show up on that battlefield that day and
started digging right the roman side
would have seen them doing it
a goofy scene of a bunch of gladiators
first making a nice defensive ditch and
then ignoring it and jumping over it
you've made all that effort you've
neutralized the enemy that's that was
your goal right why'd you then go back
over it if that was your plan all along
why dig the ditch in the first place
it's it's just a silly silly
big fight one out of ten
these are shields that are designed for
shield wall formations they're even like
standing shields so tower shields which
are meant to be set down in battle to
form a static line of infantry usually
you would use that to set up your
defensive barrier your bulwark behind
which you would then have archers for
instance to fire at the enemy and try
and get them to attack you where you
want them so there are lots of different
cultures throughout history that have
used these kind of shield world taxes
with very large very heavy shields and
then in the medieval period they become
more popular because of the rise of
crossbows where you start to get your
armor and your small shields are no
longer adequate so you need these big
barriers to protect you when you're
doing things like reloading your own
crossbow so you get these kind of
pavisas these big tower shields
[Music]
they're setting up a catapult or a
trebuchet like very slowly inevitably
because it's very heavy and difficult to
position and then you have to move these
big balls and they actually make a point
of showing how heavy they are you're not
going to be able to fire those very
quickly
like it's going to have a very slow rate
of fire all that time they're just
exposed
and you're standing there
if you get hit by these balls you have
no one to blame but yourself
i think it's giving you every
opportunity to do something about it but
instead you're just gonna stand there
well tactically it's very bad
they do have some of the equipment
rights four out of ten
thanks very much for watching i hope you
enjoyed that and if you did you can
watch my other video which you can find
here